hola qué tal muy buen día recordemos que
esto es una denuncia que se realiza
desde los resultados de la elección del
pasado 21 de noviembre cuando días
después no se conocían los resultados
oficiales y no se proclamaba al
candidato aunque ya se sabía que había
ganado el opositor freddy superlano ya
como comentabas se han denunciado por
parte de organizaciones no
gubernamentales que se ha reforzado esa
presencia militar desde el plan
república se habla de que son 24.000 los
funcionarios que van a custodiar los
centros de votación en todo el estado
barinas sin embargo ya el candidato
opositor es sergio garrido se ha
pronunciado al respecto y ha dicho que
eso se trata de una forma de amedrentar
a los ciudadanos durante esta polémica
elección ya que es una repetición de los
comicios del pasado 21 de noviembre en
los que por primera vez en 22 años un
candidato opositor
derrotaba al chavismo en esa entidad que
la ha gobernado durante 22 años se habla
además de que hay fuerte presencia de
otros cuerpos de seguridad
en este despliegue que se ha realizado
para que hoy más de 600.000 ciudadanos
en el estado barinas acudan a las urnas
para elegir al gobernador